apple has always been notorious for
their ludicrous pricing
from their 1 000 pro stand to their new
airpods max but though we still see all
of these headlines describing
apple's latest premium price product
apple has actually been carefully
pulling back on the apple attacks over
the past couple of years
while trying their best to not have
anyone notice and
here's how
[Music]
starting off smartphone sales have
actually started to decline
over the past couple of years this isn't
because smartphones were just a fad
and that they're dying or anything like
that rather
smartphones have been out for over a
decade at this point
and basically everyone who wanted one
and can afford one
already has one if we take a look at the
smartphone penetration rate in the us
we can see that the adoption rate has
actually been slowing down since 2010.
more recently since 2017 the penetration
rate has almost gone sideways
and will likely see a plateau in the
mid-to-70s
this decade despite this apple didn't
feel too much pressure from plateauing
and even decreasing sales within the u.s
and other western countries as
developing countries
specifically china and slightly india
made up for the discrepancy
however the rich consumers in those
countries also started to dry up by the
late 2010s
aside from this not only were less
first-time buyers entering the
smartphone market
but people who already had a smartphone
were upgrading
less often smartphones were lasting
longer than ever before
and more importantly the new releases
every year weren't that enticing
anyways again this isn't necessarily a
bad thing
smartphones have enjoyed rapid
innovation in the past
but today they have nearly reached their
peak form
considering all of this it's no wonder
why apple's iphone sales figures started
going sideways
beginning in 2015. a bigger telltale
sign that apple expected sales to even
start going down
was their policy change near the end of
2018 where they stopped reporting iphone
sales figures
with all of that being said it's no
question that it was time for a change
in game plan but apple has an image to
keep up
so they can't just go out and admit that
sales are decreasing
and so they're gonna slash prices that
wouldn't be a very smart idea
instead apple approached the issue in a
much more controlled
and strategic manner their first step
would be changing the marketing material
for the iphone xr
for the first time in their history
apple would advertise the trading price
of the iphone xr
on the main apple page they pushed ads
showing that the xr
only cost 449 dollars a piece but to
actually get it for that price
you would have to trade in a minimum of
an iphone 7 plus
this was an extremely surprising move
from apple
sure everyone complains about apple's
pricing
but their marketing and business ethics
were never in the question
the truth was apple had never stooped as
low as using arguably deceptive
marketing
until now they did eventually realize
that this was a bad move for the overall
brand
and they have gone back to advertising
the retail price as they should
after this fiasco apple would actually
decrease the price of the entry phone
for the first time
the iphone xr started at 750 in 2018
but the iphone 11 would start at 700 in
this would be the closest that apple
would get to admitting that they might
have pushed the price a bit too far with
the iphone xr
following this though apple wouldn't
straight up reduce the price of their
new phones again
they wouldn't be as quick to discontinue
older versions
on top of this just earlier this year in
april
apple would release a super budget
smartphone the iphone sc second
generation
coming in at 400 and if you haven't
noticed yet
this has allowed apple to have a phone
available at every single 100
price increment between 400 and 800
dollars
this pattern breaks at the 900 mark but
that doesn't really matter
as people who are looking at the pro
series are buying to get the best iphone
available
as opposed to getting the best value
iphone but even in the pro lineup
apple is much more price sensitive today
with the iphone 12 pro max
apple actually slightly increased the
screen size in comparison to the iphone
11 pro max
they also increased the storage capacity
of the entry model for the pro series
from 64 gigabytes to 128 gigabytes
and they also added a couple of notable
internal upgrades for the max
considering that this is apple and the
fact that samsung recently released
their flagship
the note 20 ultra for thirteen hundred
dollars many people expected the iphone
12 pro max to start at 1200
or even 1300 but apple stuck to eleven
hundred dollars
now that's still quite expensive but it
does show apple's more cautious approach
to further price increases
anyways going back to their cheaper
models the assortment of phones clearly
shows apple's effort in eliminating
entry price as a recent people to use
android
over apple but the most surprising thing
for me
was actually the iphone se page on this
page
apple actually has a section called have
an android
see why you should switch this move is
extraordinary
apple has always practiced the idea of
acting like competition doesn't exist
when it comes to marketing
apple stance since the 1980s has been
very straightforward
if you're looking for cheap or value
tech feel free to shop around
if you want the best however come to us
over the years
they have never felt the need to justify
that their products are better
until now today not only do they have a
page establishing their dominance
but they even accept trade-ins of
android phones
truly quite a turnaround within the
iphone lineup itself
however the major cuts in the apple tax
are actually found
elsewhere specifically accessories and
services
take the apple watch for instance when
the original apple watch came out
the starting price was 350 but today
you can get a brand new apple watch from
their official website for
only 200 or nearly half the price
granted it is a couple of years old
though not much has really changed since
then
and this too is on purpose here apple is
taking advantage of a classic pricing
technique called
contrast pricing the idea entails
offering a more expensive product with
little added value
that makes the original product seem a
lot cheaper sure
the blood auction app and the ecg app
may be extremely helpful for a
subsection of the population
but it doesn't really matter for the
average person and
as for cellular functionality you have
to pay another ten dollars per month to
even take advantage of that feature
so unless you're looking to add your
apple watch to your data plan
the cellular functionality isn't all
that useful considering this
for the average consumer the apple watch
series 3 is basically the same
as the series 6 but it's half the price
by creating this contrast they hope that
you'll follow through with the purchase
of the apple watch series 3
as this gives them a huge advantage if
you have an apple watch
and an iphone you're much less likely to
switch over to android when you upgrade
your smartphone
as that will essentially make your apple
watch useless
as you can see apple has transitioned
the apple watch from a luxury accessory
to a practical accessory
intended to keep you in the apple
ecosystem a similar pattern can be found
with their airpods lineup
as well the original airpods are really
what they expect the average consumer to
buy
and the airpods pro and max are really
just there for contrast pricing
this strategy is even clearer with all
of their services
not a single one of those services is
premium priced
in fact they're all extremely
competitive for instance
take a look at apple music the pricing
is identical to spotify premium
across the board and for the same price
you get a larger music library
and likely a more optimized experience
taking a look at cloud storage we see a
similar story
apple's icloud pricing is identical to
google's cloud storage solution
they both charge 2.99 a month for 200
gigabytes
and 9.99 a month for 2 terabytes it
should be noted however that google's
free tier offers 15 gigabytes
as opposed to apple's free tier that
only offers 5 gigabytes
anyways finally we have the apple 1
which combines apple music
apple tv apple arcade and icloud for
quite competitive pricing
as you can see there's really no
remnants of an apple attacks
across any of their services but then
why do they still release outrageously
priced products like the airpods max
and the pro stand well the answer is
brand perception
and pr the media and social media don't
care if apple releases a budget phone
as though that's practical it's really
not that interesting
moreover apple doesn't want the media to
focus on that anyways
but what about a thousand dollar monitor
stand that accomplishes nothing more
than just
holding your monitor now that's
outrageous and exciting
by releasing such products apple is able
to control the media cycle to focus
heavily on their high priced items
which reinforces that apple is a luxury
brand that offers premium products only
they really have no intention of
actually selling very many of these
products
or making much money off of them if any
they don't even keep them in stock
taking a look at the delivery times for
the pro stand it's three weeks out
meaning that it's likely coming straight
from china and i assure you
that's not because of excessive demand
now compare that to apple's holiday
delivery deal
five dollars for two hour delivery
anyways
at the end of the day due to declining
smartphone demand
apple has slowly but consistently
decreased the entry price on their
primary products
and accessories to incentivize more
customers to switch to apple
meanwhile they're offering extremely
competitive services
in order to get a strong hold on their
customer base despite the trend towards
lower prices
apple continuously chucks out
ridiculously priced products to
reinforce the premiumness
of their brand and this has allowed
apple to be more profitable than
ever before despite decreasing iphone
revenue
evidently their innovation when it comes
to technology may have stalled
but their innovation when it comes to
business is stronger than ever
and it's no wonder why they're one of
the fastest growing companies in the
world
despite already being at the top how do
you guys feel about apple strategy
overhaul
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video explained
apple's master plan
well and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
you